all right ladies and gentlemen
witches and wizards Muggles and squibs
people of all ages everybody's welcome
all right I'm gonna try something a
little different instead of waiting till
I
still instead of waiting until the
starting soon screen is over I'm gonna
try
see I'm wasting time already by even
telling you guys this I just need to
jump right into it Natasha first chatter
I saw tonight
Natasha thank you so much for being here
early feathers in the house as well both
Natasha and Feathers channel members
here
Shadow win925 I recognize that name good
to see you back again Noob Alicia DJing
Shadow guided all channel members right
there Brittany Smith is back with us
again as well lowercase Logan what's up
my friend
oh dude you know what
there was a much easier way to probably
do this actually no no no there's not
never mind
Professor Abbott
welcome Tokyo Kai I think it's Chimera
but it's like cymera
let's see do we get Noob Noob welcome
back good to see you here Channel member
right there Jason Ingram Jason how's it
going
plumb bob Kingdom welcome back Plum Bob
Moon Lily
I think I remember that name too
welcome back Moon Lily guys it is it is
so cold right now
it's cold where I live and it now it's
it's pretty cold in my house my wife
loves keeping it cold so I just have to
put on more layers so
I got the hoodie on
the toboggan on
headphones on top of that nice wool
socks dude I totally get what Dumbledore
meant man when he looked in the mirror
of ariset and said that he saw himself
with a pair of thick Woolen socks
I get it I do
David armis
Channel member welcome back David
Let's see we got Jason I see Neil Harris
in his back what's up Neil
Nico dude how did Nico oh and he
retracted the message
Nico's mod I thought somehow his message
got
oh that's funny
it didn't look like the stream element
spot was working Nico I saw you trying
to
link the Discord
no idea what was going on with that
I'll try it again here in a second
well we made it through a few of the
names before we hit the go live
no wrong one see I always hit the wrong
one 132 people in here though let's go
this is the one I meant to hit right
here
[Music]
that's a little loud I wish I could get
that to be just a touch quieter
man this is a different Halloween music
tonight it's a little bit more a little
bit more low-key it's the same uh
[Music]
same same
Creator as last time Lo-Fi geek I got a
link to it in the description
but this one doesn't even feel at least
not yet I've only been listening for a
bit but doesn't feel that Halloween to
me
all right let's see if I can catch up
here really quickly with people I missed
Miller what's up Miller IMO Josh one
with the sword
nice I like that name one with the sword
see we got David we got Shadow we got
jelly in the house CJ now there is I the
thing that I said might be easier is
there is a little thing where I can just
look at all participants
but I don't know is that only people
that are chatting because if people are
lurking I don't want to call them out if
they don't want to be called out you
know
CJ Channel member in the house as well
Jake is back with us jelly Afton what's
up jelly welcome to the stream Jenny is
here as well Halle Berry is here with us
once again
foreign
getting us started off
with a super chat right there hey retro
how would you feel about some gifted
Subs going around
I mean I'm not gonna complain dude I'm
not gonna complain but totally
not necessary you guys always go above
and beyond with the gifteds and the uh
[Music]
the super chats to start the stream so
thank you very much it's kind of crazy I
turned off slow mode tonight so we'll
see how this goes Amore poet if you in
if you're in here
I was thinking of you I turned off slow
mode
honestly because we get so many gifted
memberships in here that we realized
last time that if you're gifted a
membership
then slow mode doesn't affect you anyway
so it's like
it's only affecting the like you know 10
15 people who aren't members like right
now the little chat box I'm looking at
I'm catching up on names for everybody
here but the chat box I'm looking at
it's like 90 green which means you're a
member here
Albury is here Katrina McKinney Channel
member is here as well Zach what's up
Zach welcome okay stream elements says
the bot is running now
again that was a while ago though
Jake oh my goodness Jake with the 999
Super Chat nah I'm gonna be first how
many times have I been in a row what do
you what do you mean how many times have
you been first like first one here in
the Stream
Jake oh my Jake a regular supporter of
the stream Jake thank you so much dude
good to hear from you hope everything's
going well
yeah man I'm telling you guys I got the
I got the toboggan on tonight I got the
hoodie on
the socks that I have
they're the best pair of socks I I've
ever owned my wife thinks I was kidding
like last year she got them for me for
Christmas I was like this is one of the
greatest gifts
Christy Jean
what's up Christy how's it going
thank you so much uh okay let's see we
got Jenny here
we get stream elements we got zutara
babe09 and there's
there's Ellen
I mean Ellen just spoiling us so much
here myself and expecto go starting off
the stream with another five gifted so
two super chats
then a uh what's what do you call it
like a re-up a
H because on Twitch it's like a re-sub
Christie like re-upped her membership
then we get five gifted from L1 L one
thank you so much as always for your
support
those of you seeing your name pop up
right here you just got a gift of
membership here on the channel make sure
you think Elwyn and you will be able to
uh use all these emotes that you see
people spamming
you'll be able to use those in the chat
you get a discount on merch you get
um well now we know you're not affected
by slow mode in the chat so that there's
another benefit
and there's Christy with a with a gifted
membership as well
Christy thank you so much for that gift
membership let's see who got that one
Nicholas Olson
welcome to Griffin congratulations
Nicholas you just got gifted a
membership to Retro raconteur live
and then noob
with the 10 gifted memberships
all right nearly headless Nick dude take
it away
take it away Game Zone with a gifted
membership Noob thank you so much
seriously you guys are too much man you
guys are too much
can't even get through the get through
thanking everyone welcome everybody
and then there's Carlos coming in Carlos
with the uh I don't think that's a super
chat I think it's like a highlighted
comment or something Carlos I see you
buddy or a sticker that's what it is
Carlos thank you so much for the sticker
there
Paul Barry
just got one of the gifted memberships
it's so weird when I look over at this
monitor there's like a big mic in my
face
it really is Gallifrey it really is
they are too kind far too kind
brick plays with a gift of membership
right there guys if you just got gifted
make sure you thank the person that
gifted it to you I know a lot of times
people they're in YouTube streams for
the first time
and they don't really know like how it
how it works like what exactly what
exactly is going on what did they just
do so those of you who are getting
gifted membership somebody paid for you
to get that gifted membership so it's
just a fun way to support the stream and
it's ways that I can throw you a little
something fun in return like the emotes
and then wait did we just get Gryffindor
lowercase Logan with another five gifted
my goodness lowercase Logan dude thank
you so much okay we
we've gotta check
I owe you guys speaking of like perks
giving back in return I owe you guys
some emotes or Emoji I think I think
YouTube calls him emoji
we have unlocked
hold on I'll tell you guys exactly how
many we've unlocked
Jason Ingram
becoming a member once again three
months for Jason
oh it was a super chat from Carlos there
we go thank you so much Carlos
Jason thank you so much for becoming a
channel member once again and then oh
dude nearly had listening it's gonna be
busy all night long
take it away Nick take it away my friend
we got five more coming right up
there's Machop re-upping Machop with the
three months
what's up Machop thank you so much
like guys what is going on
what is what is happening
I know we got a little bit of news today
that we're gonna talk about you guys are
excited about that
but it's not there's not a lot going on
[Music]
I mean Noob yeah let me see if it shows
on the uh
I think it shows on the no it doesn't
show
I know
how are you shows new members
it shows 22 new members
so I don't know if that even counts the
the re the re members who are already
members and are just like re-upping
oh my goodness Oni savior is back as
well only savior with a two dollar Super
Chat start counting I know right
okay
okay I was like wait what now what now
guys
honestly this is too much man this is
too much
well in all honesty I
I don't have firm plans yet but because
of how insanely generous you guys are
being right now I want to go ahead and
at least
tell you guys that are here right now
what I've been kind of thinking I want
to do something to get back I really do
and there's a lot of big streamers that
I'm a fan of who every year they do
something around the holidays like some
big big giveaways
and I want to do something like that
around around Christmas time you know
even if you don't celebrate Christmas
just just celebrating as a time of
giving
and you guys have shown so much love to
the stream this year I mean it's crazy
man it's crazy duh not even just I mean
the YouTube channel is doing well yes
but the the love and support you guys
are showing the streams
that's like on another level man it's on
another level
did it get to two months there from
DJing DJing thank you so much for the
two months love how supportive the
people here are you are all amazing they
right
for real DJing way to show the love and
so I want to try to show it back I like
I said I have no firm plans I was
literally just thinking about this today
but I want to do something like that man
and I don't know
if it I mean if it's just a bunch of
five dollar amazon gift cards if it's if
we can secure something big to give away
I want to do some giveaways now the
problem with giveaways is like
I'm doing my first giveaway right now
actually through um we actually had our
first sponsor video Harry Potter
Hogwarts mystery if you guys haven't
haven't seen this check our community
page or my Twitter and you'll see see
that but um giveaways there's like a lot
of logistics to work through with
giveaways and how exactly like you got
to be clear on the rules and everything
and how you're gonna do it
and then I really want to do physical
items what I'd love to do is go buy a
bunch of like Harry Potter related
things
and do a just like give a bunch of that
stuff away
courage
c-u-r-a-n-j my apologies if I
mispronounce that but quran's just came
through with a 20 Super Chat are you
kidding me dude thank you so much
what
you guys
[Music]
how are you this is like this is too
much man this is too much
are you guys that pumped about the news
tonight are you that pumped about these
two new clips
and then V one dar
just became a channel member as well Dr
Robo Panda just re-up for two months one
of the best communities
thank you so much Dr Robo Panda I I
agree I agree
I mean I'm like I'm at a lot I mean I
know we kind of start we
there's usually a couple people who
always show up at the beginning of
streams and sell show love so I'm a
little I'm spoiled I admit
but tonight there's like a bunch of
newcomers too
I mean guys
seriously
take care of yourself
take care of your family take care of
your friends
and if you have a little bit left over
and you want to throw it my way it's all
good but please I know a lot of people I
get comments every now and then from
people who when they see all this and
it's fun right I mean I get the hype
everybody loves it when stuff like this
happens
but I don't want people to feel left out
either the people who are like oh I wish
I could donate something or
do not feel at all like please don't
feel left out you were just as much a
part of this community
I really do mean that I really do mean
that I don't want anybody to ever feel
obligated and I don't want anybody to
ever feel like Oh I wanna you know
just to get my name read or something so
if like I said if if you are secure all
of you right now that are donating and
showing this love thank you so much
really I I truly appreciate it but I
know times are hard for a lot of people
right now and I mean that's what
honestly it's it's humbling like really
that you guys would share even a little
bit of what of what you make with me
it's awesome man
and I'm like so far I'm like I'm so far
behind on confidence my apologies I'm so
far behind
but seriously I always just try and I
want to make that clear you know never
never feel like you're not part or
never feel obligated like you have to
give anything so
yeah I see some people saying they're
like they can't figure it out it is
Mobile's kind of weird I don't think you
can do everything on mobile Shadow
guided why do I have the option to cheer
for something from last week who knows
Shadow guided but throw it on in there
it's all good Shadow guided with the two
months I'll give you another shout out
Shadow guided I don't know if we
shattered it out last time or not but
there you go have another
have another
and see now the comments are just like I
mean all right hold on hold on I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it here we go okay we
got Jason we got Katrina
we got Nico pilot Joseph what's up I see
you pilot
and we got a new uh sub there as well we
got Jake we got Moon Lily
okay seeing a lot of the repeats okay
good good good no profile name
all right if I missed you guys
I know we just had the chat does that
thing where it like just jumped and
skipped a whole bunch of people
[Music]
so I'm just gonna catch up here with the
uh
scroll to like the most recent page here
Chad I might get in trouble by Nico
again just
oh dude Jake thank you so much that was
funny last time
I actually don't know if Nico manually
triggered that or if it was um
it was like the Auto mod or something
speaking of the of the bot let's see if
it's working now exclamation point
Discord
come on come on you can do it
way to go stream elements way to go
retro guy gaming I have no idea what the
news is for today so I'm excited
we got two new clips from Hogwarts
Legacy they're little I mean they're
minor Clips but it is it is something
new something fun to discuss
J with the 1.99 Super Chat
CJ
do it with this little this Emoji right
here
quiet everyone quiet the music feels a
little loud but I think it's just in my
headphones I'm gonna turn it down a bit
[ __ ] let's hates me
oh I wonder if I have to give you some
kind of permission Nico I feel like the
YouTube permission would carry over to
that
I feel like it would carry over to that
see we turned off slow mode and look
what what happens
who am I kidding though this would
happen on
I had slow mode on Odin killer 9 just
super chatted with
it with 99 own killer thank you so he's
so welcome I don't believe I've seen
your name in here before thank you so
much for stopping by and hang out hey
retro off topic do you think our main
character is a
metamorph
oh like the uh I think it's metamorph
Magi metamorph Mages like Tonk so we can
redesign our own character anytime like
in the new Saints Row okay first of all
Odin killer you're not off topic at all
you you're very much trying to get us on
topic which I appreciate
I appreciate
that's kind of a cool idea though
I had never thought about that
but that is a that would be an
interesting way that they could make it
work to where you could change your
character's appearance at any time you
know like a lot of games have that I was
thinking of Eldon ring there was a
there's like these scars that you can
get or these burn marks you can get on
you if you do this one Quest but there's
a way that you can go and like you could
totally change your appearance and it
includes those burn marks
but that like in most games that just
never really fits this would actually be
a way for it to fit within the story
that's a cool idea I I haven't seen any
evidence to that Odin killer like I
don't think there's anything there that
leads me to believe that is happening
but I love it as an idea I think that's
a cool idea
and thank you so much for the the Super
Chat because yeah I feel like they would
have to let you
would they really lock in your character
like where you can't chant like let's
say you want to change maybe they'll
have you have it where you can change
things like hairstyles but not anything
major
throughout the game like once you start
and then new with another Super Chat
cough cough gotta do it everyone a
friendly reminder to stay yo
all right non-sponsored non-sponsored
but tonight's beverage of choice we got
the we got the Waterloo again here so
don't worry guys this the spider over
there
the spider won't mind it's all good this
is another black cherry black cherries
might go to Waterloo flavor
my go-to Ravenclaw Tyrell what's up I
see Nico noctis in the chat as well just
happy to see you live streaming Gabe I
see you in the chat as well uh brick
plays got one of those gifted membership
what's up brick plays
and then I saw somebody man there's
always a couple comments I notice
when I'm setting up for the stream
um
gosh I can't remember who it was I wish
I could remember who it was but they
said something to the effect of how much
they look forward to this every week me
too man me too I'm so glad that you guys
love this weekly time together as much
as I do I say it every week I want to do
more I really do I want to do more live
streams I want to do more not they
probably wouldn't be like this but more
gameplay stream so we're gonna get there
man we're gonna get there it's just a
matter of time
just a matter of time and honestly with
the crazy support like this you know
maybe sooner rather than later
[Music]
all right so we got that super chat
thank you so much Noob for that
Discord with a working link let's go
careless dreamer I see a careless
dreamer Timothy the ninja in the house
as well
the hogsme barber will have you covered
I like that yeah yeah yeah
Dr Sherman what's up
yeah there's always somebody Dr Sherbert
there's always somebody who's like
you're like dude
like come on now I gotta get in the bed
I'm over in the are you are you in uh
Europe Dr sherbet you are I remember
this I'm pretty sure you are they're
like come on it's like three four a.m my
time retro come on let's get to the
clips dude but then
I mean then we Ravenclaw Tyrell Raven
called Tyrell like
okay Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you so much
gifted five new memberships nearly
headless Nick my boy
let's see if I can time this just right
take it away
I shouldn't have said let's see if I can
time this I should have just went right
into it it would have been perfect
timing
would it be perfect timing
I know I missed some names guys who are
here tonight I know I missed some people
my apologies I saw Macy in here as well
oh there's Macy Macy just said hello
again Macy got one of the gifteds let's
go
how are you welcome to Griffin can't
find your airpods case even though you
just had it
that was kind of like deja vu because I
I was like wait do you see do you see
mine in the back did I leave it behind
me somewhere
someone just became a member twice wait
really
I didn't think that was possible
250 hit night
only possible due to holiday I feel that
oh sometimes stream elements repeats
white wolf what's up Tokyo Chimera looks
like Tokyo got one of the gifteds right
there
I do not Nightwing and that that's
actually getting me back to what I was
talking about earlier
[Applause]
oh my gosh did I miss that Super Chat oh
no that one okay we got that one thank
you noob
but that ties in directly to what I was
talking about a way to give back this
holiday season it's always kind of weird
I want to get physical items like I
would love to just like
load up this table back here pile it up
even pile stuff up in the Floor of
things that I'm gonna give away
but when you're giving stuff away that's
physical then you have to
you know you guys would have to give me
or a mod your address and that's always
kind of weird I mean you could trust me
promise but I don't blame you I mean
it's it's the internet Hufflepuff squid
just became a member Hufflepuff squid
that is an awesome name first of all
I love the name and thank you so much
for becoming a member
but I might just do it anyway I might
just do it anyway I might do some like
sort of e-gifts for the holidays and
then some physical gifts and if people
don't want to you know then that's
that's up to you
I feel like I remember reading something
though about there's some sort of a
website where you can
send stuff to people and it like somehow
hides the address
anyway
because I know some of you depending on
your age you know you may be too young
to even it may be your parents house you
may not want to give parents probably
trust me as a parent they do not want
you giving out their address to some
random guy online who says you could
trust me I promise
but I mean you can't trust me you can't
what stay still do that kids don't do
that to any of the kids out there just
don't do it
but I definitely uh
donation oh see look that's the kind of
community we have here Katrina
that's the kind of community we have
that's a good idea too though like
that's something I could do
that is a way to give back but it
doesn't require
you to give me an address or to uh like
ship anything but gift cards are always
easy too because you can just you know
you just need an email
amazing cjb with everyone age I'm 30
yeah Brit plays that's what we're
getting ready to talk about I promise I
promise Dr sherbet and everybody else
let's see it's uh it's 853 okay by nine
my time by nine my time seven give me
seven minutes guys seven minutes and
then we're gonna get into the news
the latest and greatest as expecto go
likes to say
so if our let me actually I can tell you
our so this is not for the live stream
but for the uh
[Music]
for the YouTube page so this is like all
viewers so not just people that watch
the live stream
over the past 28 days
okay this some of this is surprising to
me some of it isn't so for age breakdown
28 percent
of my audience on YouTube is 18 to 24.
28 the the majority is 25 to 34. that's
51.9 52 now this is just the last 28
days
sin mermaid just became a member as well
Sid mermaid welcome thank you so much
for choosing to become a member here you
just unlocked access to all these emoji
that you see people spamming
oh so a lot of there's a lot of people
in here pretty close to
wait how old are you Katrina
Trina says I'm the oldest here oh wait
maybe Katrina didn't didn't give her a
just yet oh 38 now oh come on that's not
old
that's not old
let's see I saw somebody Ravenclaw
Tyrell we're the same age
Ravenclaw Terrell and I are the same age
feathers 26 45. see this our audience
definitely skews a little bit older
they're not like um
so well like the YouTube breakdown 18 to
24 is 28 52 at 25 to 34.
12 at 35 to 44. now that's just that's
what YouTube says now here's the one
that's surprising to me
Dylan oh my gosh what is up Dylan fellow
moderator in the house yo hope everyone
is having a great week so far and has a
great night
watching our favorite dad who loves
games and the stories they tell Dylan
thanks so much for the Super Chat man
Dylan I don't know if you were here for
the beginning the beginning was insane
car Carlos
dude Carlos you don't have to Super Chat
for that
thank you so much though Carlos with the
dollar 99 Super Chat letting everyone
know he's 22.
I feel like we have a lot of
female audience members on the live
stream but according to YouTube on our
videos it is only 17.8 percent female
that's over the past 28 days let me do
uh let me do like the past the past year
that's a little bit higher 19.8 percent
female
last 365 days on the YouTube channel and
then for uh 80 mail
but I feel like we have a pretty good
amount when we do the live streams
man my allergies you guys they are
stirred up again but
I was feeling pretty bad Monday but
today I'm a lot better
wait what is dude I'm like today is just
Tuesday right how was yesterday only
Monday
foreign
just turned 35 Brandon 32 Brian 31.
Professor Abbott you can be my kids
hey it's all good
25 for Nico
27 Dylan Brittany 22
lowercase Logan says the channels at
Nathan the Channel's little brother wait
Nathan 13 yo what's up Nathan
oh my gosh okay
this is not this is don't feel bad about
this Nathan this is the more of like a
jaw dropper for me you were closer to my
son's age than my age
I have a most people here know I have
two two boys I have an eight-year-old
and a four-year-old and the
eight-year-old will be uh well he's
eight and a half basically right now
yeah
but yeah our audience is definitely a
little more like a lot of times people
think gaming YouTube you know you think
like that high school age but no our
audience is definitely a little bit
older than that
Chrissy says it's because we're louder
oh that's funny
Luca how's it going Luca welcome
oh my gosh Christy's thing popped up
again I don't know how it does that but
thank you Christy oh Christy oh wait
maybe it's because she had a different
message no I don't have a PO box yet but
now you're the second person to ask so
maybe we need to uh
I have a little uh
notes section in the notes app on my
phone where I just add kind of like a
general to-do list not like immediate to
do but things that I'm gonna need to do
actually this is one I can take off look
into upgrading hard drive option
upgrading hard drives for PC I need more
space but I already did that
I really just I ended up going with a
backup hard drive instead of a brand new
hard drive
but yeah P.O box question mark I need to
look in my area and see how much it
costs or if it's free how much or if it
does cost
but yeah Christy thank you so much for
thinking of me to send send a uh
Christmas gift I love that idea
but yeah if I do end up getting one I'll
let you guys know I'll let you guys know
probably in the I don't think I would
put that out on Twitter but probably on
the Discord
so if you're not a member of the Discord
I'll just hit it in the chat right now
exclamation point Discord you can join
there
Arcane Master considering getting a
steam deck dude I watched like three
steam Deck videos and then 50 of them
were appearing on my
home page on YouTube I was pretty I was
almost ready to buy one but
I do think I would like it but I just
like I have such a backlog now of PS5
games
and switch games that
I just I just can't I just can't right
now I know I would love it though it
seems like some really nice Hardware I
wish Sony would do another Vita man
like now that the tech is here for like
a PS5 portable that just runs everything
at like I don't know 720p 30. I love
that like that was the biggest failure
of the Vita is the the Vita itself as a
console was great it's fantastic
handheld uh but the games you know like
how are you gonna convince the developer
to make a game for just this handheld
now with technology where it's at steam
deck is showing
we don't have to do that anymore
we don't have to do that anymore
release your current games scale them
back
lower res not as many bells and whistles
but it's it's pretty impressive it
really is what steam deck can do
another Super Chat from Noob okay noob
you get a P.O box you know I'm gonna
send you niffler plushies every
Christmas
yeah speaking of nifflers I think that's
going to be one of our new Emoji all
right it is nine I promised by nine we
would go to the news so let's go to the
news the one last thing I will say is
here let me tell you how many uh
I want to tell you guys how many emoji
that I owe you all
guys so before tonight
we were over a hundred channel members
we were at 117 channel members that is
incredible man and that was before
tonight before all these new ones that
just came through
all right so let's see how many new
Emoji I need to get okay one two three
four five six we need to get six new
Emoji holy cow
bringing us to like 15 total
there's there's another Channel member
right there
per Barthel thank you so much
for this
Quran wait was that a repeat was that an
accident
you didn't mean to donate 20 again did
you quranj
exactly Noob exactly the niffler holding
the coin
yes that is my exact idea koranj
if that was another donate even if it
wasn't another donation if it if it was
an accident let me know try to get your
money back
but if it wasn't an accident thank you
so much quranj
okay wait it's cure wait c-u-r-a-n like
a river current
a river current without the tea Corrine
still can't donate members for some
reason Corinne Corinne is that right
or Curran Curran not Korean Curran
Curran thank you so much
for another big donation that's two
twenty dollar super chats
you guys are just the best
you're just the best
all right let's do it man let's get into
the news
[Music]
oh no oh no
oh no
it's doing that thing where they're all
they're all gonna repeat
they're all gonna repeat okay hold on
I'm gonna turn them welcome to see if I
can turn it off for a second and if that
will stop it Earth will still hear the
sound
I know it looks really weird right now
hold on just give it a second
all right let's bring it back now
[Music]
how are you welcome to Griffin North why
do you do that stream elements why do
you do that
[Music]
why do you do that
all right hold on maybe if I
oh my gosh dude how are you Vicky TV
what is up
all right I'm just gonna hide it I know
it looks weird right now but it's okay
we'll get through it
all right so if you guys missed this
some people were really anxious for me
to get to the news it wasn't anything
too major but
so Hogwarts Legacy official Twitter
account here
so this was back on October 5th man
since the we kind of got used to the
regular Thursdays you know for a while
since then they have been just kind of
all over the place which it's keeping us
on our toes keeping us guessing so we
had the big release of the Hogwarts
guide we had these character cards which
were pretty cool revealed some
information we were hoping that these
three were leading up to the Ravenclaw
companion reveal that did not happen uh
then on October 12th
so let's see that was what last last
Wednesday
we got this post right here so let me uh
let me actually kill
let's turn off the Halloween music
because we have got to hear this
this Hogwarts Legacy music guys and it's
again the quality it's YouTube or uh I'm
sorry Twitter compression so it's not
gonna look great in fact I don't know
how much of this you guys will be able
to
to make out here all right let's see if
we can turn the overlay back on
oh my gosh they're still going
[Music]
for you yet be quiet
it's not a new one
okay that is a new one right there just
popped in from uh from Jake had to make
it a good number I'm at 275 have to make
it 270. I'll be back on later Jake with
another 4.99 Super Chat Jake thank you
so much Jake always showing the love and
support in the Stream
all right so let's do this is like
I mean I feel like it's leading up to a
uh I think it was Dylan last time who
said maybe a Halloween
uh fall ASMR that's like spooky themed I
think you nailed it dude I think you
nailed it
I think you absolutely nailed it I think
that's what this is kind of starting to
tease now somebody
I was watching expecto goes live stream
last week and I also saw this on the
where did I see it
the subreddit the subreddit for Hogwarts
Legacy apparently
they posted the fall ASMR they tweeted
it briefly and then took it down
I did not see it so I can't confirm it
however I saw at least two people saying
it and expecto ghost stream and then I
saw the post on the Harry Potter game
subreddit
even if they're not making it up I mean
even if they are making it up I think
it's inevitable I mean I think that is
definitely something we're getting and I
think Dylan is spot on if it was Dylan
who said it
ah
you nailed it was it you okay I thought
it was you yeah
I'm almost positive that
it was you
but yeah I think they're gonna this is
kind of a tease of it and they're just
gonna lead right into a fall ASMR that's
probably gonna be out on Halloween now
that was last week
today
we got this right here another short one
17 seconds no stop I want to build up to
the music
where will the grand staircase lead you
all right I'm going to try to turn on
the overlays again
oh my gosh
it's fine
oh dude that one was forever ago Odin
killer that was forever ago that was
like the first one
oh my goodness there's Ravenclaw Tyrell
okay
all right sorry let me do something real
quick I promise it won't take long
[Music]
is
I don't know why it does that like why
do they replay
oh man
all right I have to what I have to do is
I need to go into my stream elements
here
[Music]
dude he's so crazy and let's see this
one is my commentary overlay
overlay gallery
[Music]
how are you welcome to Gryffindor all
right so I'm going to turn off alerts
temporarily
all right so let's hit save
oh there's our ghost too oh we just did
we just lose the chat we just lost the
chat too I think it probably refreshed
everything that's why
all right now
we're we're reset let me turn it back on
and then we're gonna lose chat again I'm
gonna save it
all right there we go
boom okay sorry about that man I I
I switched away from stream Labs like a
year or so ago
oh but man I'm starting to think I might
have to switch back
stream elements is great in a lot of
ways but there are just so many things
little quirks that cause a problem
no bad stream set up hey Mary how's it
going thank you
oh yeah R.I.P to Robbie Coltrane indeed
indeed
very very sad and that that clip of him
from the uh
the HBO thing they did oh just hits home
even more I kind of got the idea when
they recorded that it almost sounded
like I don't know what his health
situation was but it almost sounded like
he was kind of
expecting it to happen
soon is the way it sounded
you guys trying to get get back up at
the
dude Christy that's a great idea
Hagrid Emoji I love it
all right you guys are giving me all see
I'm adding this to my little uh Notepad
so
I'm thinking a bow truffle that's waving
oh that's hard to do when it's really
small I somebody said the wand yes
somebody mentioned that a previous time
a wand I think like almost in that exact
like the wands up with the the light so
it looks like lumos a niffler with a
coin something to do with a broom or
Firebolt and then I do like the idea of
hagrah
okay this one is actually new moon Lily
just became a channel member Moon Lily
thank you so much welcome
I know you've been here hanging out for
a while thank you so much for choosing
to become a channel member here very
much appreciated Moon Lily glad you uh
want to become part of our growing
Community here I do have homework
Ravenclaw you guys are giving me
homework for sure
PS1 Hagrid oh my gosh we could actually
do the PS1 Haggard
Felix felicis potion
all good ideas I like it
yeah so like now that I reset it the
alerts are fine but it's like
everything that played on that first
scene started playing again so here's
the one that they released
earlier today they ended up releasing
two just to give you guys a little
preview that
is definitely outside the norm so it's
only 17 seconds the post here where will
the grand staircase lead you hashtag
Hogwarts Legacy 17 seconds long
Oni savior with a two dollar donation
for Robbie
wands up for Robbie Coltrane indeed
had to grab my PC to join mobile so
finicky does a light joint yeah that's
what I hear a lot Moonlight that mobile
gives people a lot of trouble
so it correct me if I'm wrong we've
gotten a glimpse of the grand staircase
before but never quite like this and I
saw somebody saying the shame about the
quality yeah it really is I wish they
would just upload these as like I don't
know even YouTube shorts or something
but then it'd be vertical so but I wish
we had them in better quality
but unfortunately this is all we got but
here's here's a couple things we can
appreciate number one the music listen
to this listen to this
[Music]
so good man
so good
[Music]
turn it down we'll let it replay a bit
so I want to know what you guys if
you've uh watched this have you spotted
anything
I I don't feel like we're meant to find
a ton here obviously we see the little
floating I think it's a book up here
or a floating page
we talked a lot about the field guide on
a previous episode and how
you can see in the trailer we're going
to be walking around and collecting
Pages whether that's like a side quest
or whether that's something to do with
with spells whether it's like the lost
and found notice board from the old
games
we don't really know exactly
but I think this is definitely further
hinting at that now in terms of the
portraits the quality is so kind of
blurry I mean all I see a little bit of
movement here like I definitely see that
these are moving
down here I don't know that I see
anything moving here
Noob with another wait didn't you just
wasn't that just no it was Oni savior
who said for Robbie now Noob wands up in
the chat for the legend Robbie Coltrane
please and thank you again stay hydrated
I gotcha Noob I got you and thank you so
much
for the Super Chat yet again
now you guys are making me feel bad that
I don't have the uh there you go Dr
sherbet's got a nice uh
way of doing it I need I definitely need
to get an emo for that though
definitely an emote
oh I like that question Timothy we'll
try to get to that here
[Music]
all right so
hold on I saw somebody say I think we
will have a feeling we'll be trying to
look at a portrait and figure out
who it is and the staircase will change
we'll have to wait until it comes back
around again to continue detailing
portraits don't seem to be moving yeah
they didn't at first to me but then
excuse me these right in here
I definitely see movement uh I don't
think I see any on these down here but
again it could just be as subtle as the
eyes and because of the quality we can't
even really notice
what do you guys think about this design
though it's different from the movies
which I'm
I'm okay with I wasn't a huge fan of the
movie design for the grand staircase
especially when they had the remember
when they had the fat lady like right
off the grand staircase they changed it
after the first two movies
to where she was like I'm pretty sure it
was POA
Prisoner of Azkaban when she's just like
right there at the top of the staircase
when she's actually supposed to be at
the end of a of a long corridor
don't see a single door
oh yeah I don't either DJing yeah
I almost feel like this is from the
perspective of
we're like standing in front of a door
probably and looking up
then we've got the waned boars over here
Jason hasn't seen anything
there are no staircases well I think
isn't that what these
like if it shifted they they would need
to shift and connect to like from here
to here
I feel like
so again not not a lot to really break
down there but
let's go to our pal Chandler wood here
because then he said
Chandler wood
he teased this very early
an iconic location in the castle you
know we had to make the grand staircase
something to behold and that music this
team is doing some amazing work by the
way you should see what it looks like at
night
dot dot dot so we're thinking okay maybe
a couple days later we'll get the the at
night no a few hours later
so this was like a this was just one
hour ago they posted this like right
before I was setting everything up for
the stream here
the castle isn't only meant to be
explored during the day now
this one I feel like gives away a little
bit more because they're starting to
play up this idea of sneaking around the
castle they know it's something
everybody wants to do
because we've been asking for it for a
long time but when you take this and
we're gonna watch this one here in a
second don't worry but when you take
this
and also consider what awaits you in the
Forbidden Forest
then you go back to the field guide post
here
[Music]
when it says this right here Hogwarts is
full of secrets common rooms are no
extent they're really playing up this
idea of Secrets and exploration and
I'm even gonna go out on maybe an extra
limb and say being able to do all these
things outside sort of the structured
like you know yeah you're on a mission
but you're gonna get you're gonna see
things that Sidetrack you which is
exactly what we want then there was
another one let's see
right here this one about the restricted
Restricted Section just a suggestion
don't get caught implying hey you're
going to be able to sneak around the
restricted section of the library
and I think was there one more classroom
was made for Mischief so it doesn't like
quite speak to sneaking around
and then peeves of course we know we
need to avoid peas oh and then the the
secret dueling Club Crosswinds dueling
Club
and then there it is like they straight
up say forbidden for a sneak off in the
Forbidden Forest and live to tell the
tale
and then fast forward to today the most
recent post and we have this right here
so it's the same exact
hold on I want to make sure I get this
right yeah it's the exact same
perspective exact same shot it looks
like they have just changed the internal
clock of the game
and let's get the music on this one
because
you'll be disappointed to hear
it's just the crackling of the fire
oh and I totally did see that portrait
move this time that portrait down here
I still see that book flying around up
there too
okay we can see the portrait move here
see the kind of uh
Lantern flickering right there
I don't know why they didn't wonder why
they didn't put music with this one
you guys are talking about Kotor in
there in the chat now
all right this is no longer Hogwarts
music
but I am going to keep this up for a bit
just to see what
I hope it has Ray tracing I think it
will
Dustin what was that bar thing I'm not
sure you might have to
I'm gonna know I'm a little behind in
the comments because I was recapping it
nighttime staircase video with the fires
reminds me of the digital Christmas
fireplaces right
ball thing floating at top of the room
probably talking about on the other one
[Music]
yeah we don't need the music now
the ball thing like this right here the
portrait there
with the big light shining on me it's so
hard to
see the darker scenes sometimes
is that a cat or something I think that
looks like a little
cat down here
in that portrait
dying to go up the astronomy Tower right
yeah Olimar even Dumbledore was talked
about how he didn't know all the secrets
of the castle
the art and making of Hogwarts I've got
it pre-ordered Dustin
shocking that it doesn't come with the
collector's edition
shocking a second post today right Dylan
right they faked us out
they did indeed do a second post today
Knights of the Old Republic is the best
Star Wars game it's it's good I remember
playing it in I think I played it in
college actually
Halloween ASMR in the Forbidden force
would be amazing I think it's gonna
happen feathers I do maybe not only
oh is it only gonna be Forbidden Forest
though I don't think it'll be only
Forbidden Forest I think that'll be one
of the of the scenes
because they use usually do what like
four or five different scenes
we had this shot in the
Christy with a super chat the five
dollar Super Chat Christy thank you so
much in the night when you can see a
light coming through a possible doorway
on the bottom right
all right let's take a look
oh like right in here
yeah it looks like there's a again the
quality on this is so bad
just the compression on Twitter I think
it's another one of these little like
Lantern style lights right here
and it's just kind of blocked by this
[Music]
dude we're gonna be so busy exploring
this Castle though
and speaking of the art and making
Dustin oh I hope it's like imagine all
the stuff like this that's gonna be in
there
so interested in how in-game time will
work I agree
I agree the more I think about it
I think it's gonna have to be
like right now I'm leaning toward it
being like a quote unquote endless day
so I don't think they're gonna put you
on an actual timer
I could be wrong I could be wrong
because I feel like there are certain
things that have to take place in the
day and certain things that have to take
place at night I feel like there will be
a clear point of you saying like like
the old games actually where you're
saying like Okay I'm gonna end the day
we're gonna go tonight
that's sort of how I'm leaning right now
I just think it gets so complicated if
you're like
if it's an actual running clock and you
have to be at classes at certain times
I can't see them going that route
Sly the aura
I said it right you guys the aura
division we have a great look at how the
grand staircase work in the first reveal
trailer every portrait on this Castle
hey that's a good point Sly that's a
good point we could go back to the I
want to talk about uh expecto goes
ladies video too actually you know what
that's uh let me make that our chat
question
let me make that our chat question
I loved the video that he posted today
um let's see start a pull answer viewer
questions live what the heck is that
something new I've never seen that
[Music]
start a q a
okay I'm not gonna do it right now but
it's kind of always q a around here
it's always q a guys all right I'm gonna
start a poll
will
we be able to ride
dragons
in Hogwarts Legacy at any point you guys
at any point
so even if you think it's an in-game
thing
let me know what you think vote in the
poll there
all right so
foreign
s Legacy
official account doesn't even pop up
what
hey I'm not gonna complain search
Hogwarts legacy and our live stream's
the first thing that pops up let's go
by the way this is a video we posted
today
there's all sorts of uh fights going on
in the comments on this one so if you
haven't watched it yet head on over
after the stream tonight watch the video
let me know how much you hate my opinion
nah it's all in good fun though I knew
that would be a uh divisive video
but honestly I mean what I said in this
I think I think all the calm rooms are
solid and if I no matter which house if
I were Slytherin if I were Ravenclaw if
I were Hufflepuff I'd be happy I would
be happy with my common room I really
would I'm gonna vote in the poll I'm
gonna say yes
oh never mind it won't let me vote
oh no did I just I just lost did I just
lose my chat
no
don't make me
it's like the OBS has a separate um
login for my chat so now I have to log
in
all right so anyway the video that I'm
actually looking for
like where is the Hogwarts Legacy
Channel
okay here it is
videos
the reveal trailer
all right now we can get some good video
quality make sure it's on the 4K there
and the other thing I need to do is turn
off
let's mute the Halloween music for a
second
and watching this again to get the uh
the
staircase
dude it still gives me pumped man
I know we had a bunch of longer trailer
but
magic both beautiful and Powerful binds
together a long history
that common Bond we share
is the legacy of Hogwarts
um oh wait I don't know if I could play
this on stream
we'll turn it down for a second I think
we're fine because it's not the actual
add your own
yeah
edwig's theme would get me our stream
would like shut off almost immediately
okay there we go now we're good
every Corridor here we go every Corridor
every portrait there's a look at it
right there
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own magical abilities in
the classrooms of the world's most
talented professors
and while your journey begins at
Hogwarts brewing potions became in
Fantastic Beasts
and Mastery spells
there is a larger World Beyond these
walls a world filled with dangers you
can't yet imagine an ancient knowledge
rungong from this world long gone from
this world that strange and mysterious
Talent you possess may be the key to
unlocking this dormant power
your potential
is Limitless
okay I got the chat back
[Music]
the journey ahead
will reveal what you stand for rip
stream nah we're good
okay that we'll cut out that part at the
end there though
yeah all right so let's go back to the
I think this is really the only good
shot we get of it
right here around 50 49
right there
so I mean and a lot has changed like
we've seen that as these trailers have
progressed they've already changed oh
but look the uh those little lights
they're already in place we can see
those right there
and we can see how just like all of
these books shifting around here
oh dude I love how now see I always
thought it was weird how the movie just
had them how they just like just like
swiveled to me this right here this
looks way more
I mean how I would imagine it in a
magical school right then them just I
mean the way they would slide in the
movies that was almost kind of
mechanical and then we still have some
that that do that
but I love this right here just how they
just kind of appear and form
that's pretty cool
that's pretty cool
love this trailer watch this in the
Gameplay trailer at least once a week
ah
we are the writer of Hogwarts of History
I started that theory Shadow guided
I don't know if I started it but I
definitely put it out there
well I don't think we'll be the writer
we already know bathilda bagshot wrote
it but
maybe we assist her in some way
I think that'd be cool like if the field
guide is sort of the early
drafts like maybe we actually meet
Matilda in this game even if she's not a
student at Hogwarts A lot of people
think she was probably older and already
out of school
by the time that our character is there
but even if she is out of school
we could still meet her as an adult
I still want to know more about these
guys too we didn't see I don't think
we've seen them in the other trailers
and the dragons dude a lot of you are
convinced we're going to be able to ride
dragons
taking it a ton and gotten the
Hufflepuff every time are you talking
about the sorted quiz
foreign
I did not know that
pretty sure Troy Levitt former Hogwarts
Legacy Dev for those of you don't know
said they had to change the stairs from
the flying in style to a static more in
line with the movie style because it was
too slow ah I could see that causing
some problems and like getting the
visuals right on that every time
yo Dylan with the ten dollar Super Chat
on the way out good night everybody
hope you have a great rest of your
stream Dylan as always my friend thank
you for the support
thank you for the love thank you for
being a moderator here and just uh
all-around great Community member here
I mean I get it it's late guys I don't
blame you at all man gotta get some rest
use AKA exclusively on the spiders
I think so too Dustin I think I'm gonna
try to do especially here's a question I
got in one of the comments today
do you guys think we'll be able to see
uh other common rooms other than our own
I think we will
whether it's Paula juice or something
else
I do think we will
all right let's see I don't think the
other trailer was so long
but I don't feel like there was anything
with the stairs in there
we'll see though we'll take a look here
we'll let it play through again
I am sorry for damage maybe small
dragons not the giant size like maybe
not the one that we see the big one
that's featured in the trailer
just some smaller ones I think it would
be an awesome in-game thing
like imagine if that's the final
traversal piece you unlock at the end of
the game
definitely think we will get in several
common rooms yeah I think so
Josh with the sword one with the sword
heading out as well Josh have a good one
my friend
replay Squad you guys can always go back
and uh replay it watch this later on it
will stay live on my YouTube channel
so you can always go back and and
re-watch these later
put a like on that did I have I
seriously not liked the trailer
I haven't liked this one either are you
kidding me
I feel like that's a mistake I feel like
I've definitely liked that trailer at
some point
foreign
dude that's weird
JP raven fire in the house what's up
absolutely need a bat a basilisk
I feel like there will be some sort of
uh
even if we don't directly see a basilisk
or encounter one I think there will be
some sort of Easter egg I do
oh wait they didn't show any staircases
there did they
they did not
Justice for the spiders what
hey Ryan how's it going welcome
remember watching One video saying that
since there's a staircase that goes up
to the top of the Ravenclaw Tower
the players could possibly fly into
Ravenclaw that way if you try to like
sneak in by flying dude look at
Sebastian in the background on this
no dude what is with that creepy stare
I don't know if I've ever noticed that
Eerie look he has on his face right
there
I mean that's a Malfoy look if I've ever
seen one he he looks jealous of the
attention that we're getting as a new
student
[Music]
hey Christy thanks for joining the
Discord have a good night
first Common room I'm sneaking in is
Slytherin won a peak of the Black Lake
be stupid in my opinion if we can't
visit other common rooms too late to
restart my whole progression just to
enter a different room right
there would have to be I hope there are
some differences based on the house you
choose like maybe there's like one or
two specific missions that
play out a little bit differently
based on which house you're in I think
that'd be kind of fun
but not anything major
hey thank you Noob for posting the
Discord there for Nightwing appreciate
you
other houses aren't supposed to know
where the other common rooms are
yeah Harry kind of finds out
all of them eventually
and he did have to go into
two of The Well of course he goes into
Gryffindor but then he has to go into
two of the other three throughout the
books he never goes to the Hufflepuff
common room
just outside of it though I'm pretty
sure he at some point
foreign
Timothy
I'm a Gryffindor but
the first look it was not my favorite
after the full reveal though
so this right here when they showed all
this in the trailer of each the common
rooms that little brief Glimpse that we
got actually they already showed it
earlier
I wasn't a huge fan of the Gryffindor
but once we got the full reveal oh I'm
at home I'm at home there
that's mine for sure
[Music]
Dustin uh wouldn't put it past myself to
you're a wizard Harry I hope it just cut
off I asked myself to make like four
characters right off the bat progress
far enough just to see and roam around
the common rooms right
not like the trailer I know dude I know
so excited to actually to be here for an
entire stream no dog classes tonight
air quality advisory in the area
my goodness smoking fires in the area
that's not good
man right here for me it's like
I'm choking on the all the leaves are
falling right now
and every year when the leaves start to
fall I have another allergy flare-up and
my youngest has to be allergic to
whatever I am because he's having the
same
rough time right now
actually he's he's probably a lot worse
than I am because he's still so young he
can't like they he doesn't even
understand how to blow his nose yet
so you have to use all the uh if your
parent you understand if you're not a
parent it sounds like most disgusting
thing ever but the uh I think the
technical name for them is a nose
aspirator
parents call them nose suckers instead
yeah lots of those things and kids hate
them they don't like them they don't
like them one bit
yeah actually the more I talk here the
more my my throat is so scratchy tonight
[Music]
says the link is invalid no way for the
for the one that we post when you hit
exclamation point Discord
maybe he has a crush on the professor
and we're getting a little too much
attention
so we will we meet a Malfoy oh maybe
I mean we've already got Weasley's
confirmed
could definitely be some malfoys in
there too
where do I think I'll spend most of my
time in the game probably
exploring the castle I don't know if
there's like one specific spot
I'm I'm a completionist in games that I
really like and get into and enjoy
exploring I just I want to see it all I
want to get all the trophies so
Hogwarts Legacy definitely going to be a
game that we have to 100 percent
so yeah it's kind of a cop-out answer to
say the castle but
exploring the castle
exploring all around the castle
I think
yeah
Seb might hate us less if we're in his
house at the start of the game now see
like that's kind of stuff I'm talking
about Mary like
will characters treat us any differently
based on the house or will we get the
missions in a different order so like if
your Gryffindor will you meet natsai
first
if you're Slytherin will you meet
Sebastian first does it change like the
order that you can do the quests in
that'd be interesting there's where we
can see Professor fig like dude he's not
doing anything like
watch him you see him right like and
then finally he's like okay I'll I guess
I'll try to cast something
big come on dude
I wonder if that means he's like
actually falls into the companion
category or not
hey Shadow guided have a good one Mew
store I didn't even know you were here
in new store
have a good night sleep new store
Draven what's up my friend
always coming hot with the Slither it's
dude did you see that stare
did you see did you see the way
Sebastian was looking at the main
character
I mean
nothing to do with Slytherin it's all to
do with that
that glare from him right there
I'm gonna go PS5 Luca unless
oh my gosh unless it comes out that it's
running like 30 FPS like Gotham
is it Gotham Knights that just got the
big hole the big
disappointment with that oh man I don't
think it will because Hogwarts Legacy is
already confirmed to have a performance
mode on PS5 so I'm like why would you do
a performance mode if it's not gonna be
targeting 60
as long as it's at least 60 I'm good on
PS5 but if it's 30
I don't care about the exclusive
missions I would go PC at that point
I want I want a smooth frame rate
that's a big question Ryan
we see it in the first trailer
pretty clearly I think we see Azkaban so
I don't know if it's only going to
appear in a cut scene
or if we'll actually be going there I
think it'd be awesome if we went there
for like a mission
so I'm not gonna rule it out but I don't
know if I would say
I just noticed this little uh
container over here for the first time
okay you got it
oh Nico's talking about the Nico did you
did we figure out what was going on with
uh
was it night shadow
was saying did you get the Discord link
working
[Music]
just a child that's jealous Sebastian
if you're a Ravenclaw you meet fig first
fake Ravenclaw companion
found out on the Discord have a micro
Community I I was I followed that elwin
I didn't get a chance to reply but yeah
that was crazy that's too cool
I've never been to Canada myself
probably have a specific area that I go
to whenever I turn the game off
people will probably care if you kill in
front of them everyone loved Wolverine
he was young even though he killed and
tortured while in school
think he had to do that like outside of
school right
noob
with another Super Chat want me to copy
paste the
link
I don't think it'll let you unless
you're a mod
unless Nico knows how to allow it
okay in Troy's interview with Alex
comment about the stairs is it 51-12 oh
okay
so let's watch this
oh my gosh what the heck
it opened it and completely the wrong
window
foreign
do I need to change the one that I have
the command set up for
if I do I'll change it
if you're really that far behind it yeah
it's just what happens you know it's
what happens
foreign the nature of these
conversations like I read one comment
and then we go super in depth
let's let you if you post it
nice Nico
oh Nick wait that was Nico with the
Super Chat there
oh that one expired okay so is is that
one set up to never expire right there
if it is I'm gonna go ahead and post a
foreign
[Music]
okay so I need to make a brand new one
all right back to my to-do list
you guys are keeping me on my toes
tonight
okay let's see new Discord link for live
stream
that won't expire
nice
how do you become a member
um
we'll see if this one works let's see if
this command Works no identity
there you go
that'll tell you
by the way I think my favorite new
area of the Discord are the pets
gosh
all right so I'm gonna
goodness this is so weird how it
like if I click that link that Nico's
linked to
okay wait it's just
it opens it up in my OBS chat box
instead of opening it in a
an actual browser window
Dr Sherman with another Super Chat
uh go in the description oh do I have I
have a good one down there thank you Dr
sherbet for the Super Chat
that's right yeah see I knew I had one
down there
yeah there's a link in the super in the
uh description of the video that should
be one that doesn't expire
all right I gotta figure out how to get
this get to this link dude
I know a way to do it
I know a way to do it if I go here
no not there
wrong place
okay right here
all right I'm gonna have to scroll way
back up in the chat but I think this
should work
I think this should work
Noob is that another
oh my gosh Noob with another
are you kidding me noob
a special role for me the hydration
reminder
was that asking for more kylo pictures
retro
was that asking for more kylo pictures
oh
dude anytime people would I was like
wait kylo
what are you talking about here then I
remembered the pet yeah yeah yeah hey
anytime people want to post more the
pets I am so down for that
I don't think my wife's ever heard of
Discord but if I show her one look at
that
new area we have there I think she might
have to join I think she might actually
have to join
okay scrolling's through here looking
for Nico's comment again in a different
chat area
because the OBS chat okay here it is
let's see if this one will work
oops something went
you've got to be kidding me
all right we're just gonna go to Alex's
interview
all right we just ended the poll too
we'll be able to ride dragons 66 ended
up saying yes 33 said no that is out of
182 votes
182 votes
all right so podcast now Troy Levitt I
think it's the second interview
that is my guess
all right 51 12.
hey what's up Alex welcome to the stream
my friend
Troy how's it going welcome
all right this is uh
so guys if you haven't checked this out
already this is from Alex's uh interview
with Troy Levitt who previously worked
on Hogwarts Legacy rocking a Slytherin
hat here he made a comment about the
staircases I totally forgot about that
Nico
all right so let's mute the music here
let's turn this up answer or not uh is
the grand staircase there or did it here
we go here it is quick one
um so here's what I'll say about the
grand staircase the early version that
you saw in the very first trailer the
part that I said I liked but then I
think what you end up in the game so
there you go there's there's a small
small reveal yeah well uh here I think I
can probably say this because I was
working on the castle what we discovered
about making the the stairway build up
like that you know because it was like
you can see it in the film it was
building up underneath you it was too
slow for a player players didn't want to
wait for the thing to come around so we
had the play test faster way to make the
grand staircase do its thing that
wouldn't slow players down and that's a
lot of what you're doing when you're
making a game as you're like thinking oh
man see I thought the visuals of it were
so that's hold on that's what he just
said you're doing when you're making a
game as you're like thinking oh that's
really cool what's it like when you
experience it that's what I was thinking
Troy dang it's a little too slow or the
timing's off but we need to adjust it
make it better so um you know that it's
a very iterative process it's always
responding you don't know what you have
in a game until you experience it and
and I think it's really important for
players and developers to recognize that
you can talk all day long about what you
think would be good but until you
actually get in and play it it's a good
point you don't know what you have yeah
often changes yeah that's even that is
exactly what I was thinking Troy like oh
dude this looks so cool
and then Troy like being you know a game
developer letting us know what's
actually going on there
thank you Nico glad you pointed that out
I did not remember that at all and do we
have another let's see
uh Super Chat yo from vamon's tongue
thank you so much for the Super Chat
love the content any idea on length of
playtime well nothing official there's
been a lot of uh us guessing and
speculating
but I haven't seen anything official I
mean I'm thinking
if it's an open world action RPG
for story
just for story
I'm somewhere between
I'll say 30 hours
I was gonna say between 25 and 30.
but for open world action RPG I feel
like 30.
and then I feel like 40 for taking your
time
and then hopefully like 50 plus for a
completionist
s
man excuse me
cats in the Discord confirm I don't know
if that was a joke about my cat allergy
or if cats if you're just commenting
that we now have some people posting
cats in the Discord
if it was a joke about my cat allergy
that was like spot on very timely of you
let's look up I'm gonna look up some uh
so there's a website out there
called I think it's called either how
long to beat
or time to beat
yeah it's howlongtobeat.com
so I'm gonna do Elden ring
so l oh my gosh okay Eldon ring the main
story the main story is 54 hours now
this is at these are averages main plus
extra is 98 and a half completionist is
132.
okay let's do Skyrim
okay Skyrim oh my gosh that's crazy
Skyrim the main story is only 25 and a
half hours
but
listen to this main plus extra
115 hours completionist 211.
let's try Witcher 3.
I mean because I'm just trying to think
of like recent
action RPGs which are three main story
51 hours main plus extra 103
completionist once it so maybe I'm
underestimating
I hope I am if this game is 51 hours of
the main story
oh my gosh okay let's try
um let's do like ghosts of tsushima
because I know that's not a I mean it's
not really an action RPG but
few RPG elements I guess it's 25 hours
ghost of tsushima for the main story
main plus extra 45 and a half completion
is 61 okay so maybe I'm underestimating
guys
I hope I am I really do
Danny have over 500 hours in Skyrim and
400 and Oblivion
Skyrim is forever
see
and it's also one thing like when I
think of once I get the platinum trophy
in games I'm usually done very rarely
will I continue to go and explore unless
there's just like a bunch more missions
that I want to do even if they're side
missions I'll do that
like I have the Skyrim
platinum trophy let me see if there's
there's got to be a way I can sell how
many hours
if I look at PSN profiles
let's see if this shows me how many
how many hours I've spent on a game
oh man it doesn't but I think that's the
thing you can see on
on your PlayStation now I'm pretty sure
you can see that
I'm not seeing anywhere that says the uh
I probably put a couple hundred hours
into Skyrim too it wouldn't Shock Me
give me like 40 plus 80 yeah like a 40
hour story
oh my gosh that'd be amazing
in the Discord as well brick plays
foreign
I did see that Owen I saw you posted
that and actually I had it pulled up
right here
I was working on it
before the stream I was trying to finish
it out and then I was like you know what
I'll just finish that on stream and now
I completely forgot about it
thousand plus hours of Skyrim for you
yes yes so this is a new thing
Elwyn just posted this in the Discord
let me get the link for you guys
are you serious
Curran
hope I pronounced it right that time
current with another 20 Super Chat
Curran my friend
dude thank you so much apologies if
you've already answered this but do you
think the wand type is going to change
anything also I think this is going to
be larger than the Witcher 3.
I would love that dude I would love that
if it's if it's longer Bigger Than The
Witcher 3
that's incredible I mean I know The
Witcher 3 is kind of kind of old but
it's still a pretty big game
that would be awesome
[Music]
as for the wand type
[Music]
my gut says no my gut says no I don't
think so
I don't think so
I just don't really know
how they would do it other than like
very small details
like maybe it casts a certain type of
spell a little bit faster
so I'm leaning toward no I'm leaning
toward I think it'll be just purely
cosmetic but thank you so much for the
donation Karen very much appreciate your
support of the stream that is incredible
dude 4am think I'm gonna call it here
looking forward to joining into
Christmas a sounds good well we do this
every Tuesday so
I know I think some people said they
were only able to join tonight because
of a holiday so
I would understand if you can't always
join because we usually start around 8
30
um Eastern Time p.m 10 53 okay
from lowercase Logan thinks that we see
the new trait of the new uh staircase
[Music]
oh you caught it
yes you did
it's very quick too I'm gonna slow it
down look at it it's like they slide in
okay I still think that's better than
the movies
oh yeah and there's a good look at the
staircase too that we we've seen now
I'm gonna rewind it again
look at it right here guys
so watch over here on the left side
right there you see a slide in
and then another slide in oh dude
that's it Logan you caught you found it
you nailed it you absolutely nailed it
and that's exactly what Troy was talking
about and I think I like that way
better than movies I like that it's not
the whole
staircase shifting I think that looks
pretty cool
okay yeah back to the the Avatar thing
though
let me just go to wizardingworld.com
it's probably linked to from their main
their main page
yeah if you just go to
wizardingworld.com
create your ultimate Wizarding World
Avatar with our new portrait maker so I
was actually in the middle of doing it
and I am not I'm pretty bald but I'm not
this bald
but I don't have that much hair either
I'm like somewhere in between
and they don't have it in between so I'm
like okay
I could go with the younger version of
me though
I do have glasses but I don't wear them
most the time oh my gosh you could do an
eye patch that's awesome you could do a
Luna Specter specs there
yeah I don't wear glasses most the time
and oh man okay
the eyebrows mine are
uh okay my eyes are kind of
[Music]
I'm not quite
I don't know that one's kinda
that's the very first one that's the
leader so far
probably a little too small
it just it was it was just just dropped
feathers like
yesterday I think
it is very new
no
I see I kind of like the eyes on that
one but the
eyebrows are a little too bushy for me
whoa
dude that's almost if you put do they
have red eyes oh my gosh
dude those are Voldemort eyes right
there
oh my gosh that is creepy look at that
hold on hold on let's go now if we go
oh my gosh bearded Voldemort
yikes
whoo
switch off of that quickly
evil retro indeed
none of the eyes are right for me yeah I
mean it is like a little Avatar thing
too so I don't guess it's meant to be
completely accurate
house with a dollar ninety nine Super
Chat house in the house house welcome to
the stream thank you so much for
choosing to support with a super chat
very much appreciate that you were too
kind too kind
what are we doing had to take my pup out
for a walk so this is a uh a new thing
on the Wizarding World
They just added this like yesterday
props to elwin on finding this
if you just go to wizardingworld.com
it's like one of the main stories right
here
and you can see it was just posted
yesterday October 17th
and so I'm just finishing mine up I had
started it before stream and then forgot
about it
foreign
I mean I hate to say it but I do like
the more I smile I am kind of starting
to get more more wrinkles around the
eyes I wish I could get this exact one
do they have this exact one without the
wrinkles I think that might be what that
one is
okay so right now I'm liking number
three oh music it is the uh it should be
in the description as well but it's this
uh Lo-Fi geek chill Halloween Beats
and I don't really like the mouth either
oh that one's pretty
[Music]
I do have sort of a smaller mouth like
this one
[Music]
nope not that one
[Music]
wait did it just change the
I think I'm gonna go with that one
not enough feminine facial structures
yeah this page was like actually I
didn't do much on this one at all yet
I was gonna try to get everything else
in place first I definitely like the I
think those
that mouth is pretty close
winner winner all right nice you guys
agree with that one okay let me take the
beard off for a second just because I
want to be able to see
I want to be able to see the facial
structure a little bit more so here's
what we were on
actually that one might be pretty close
definitely not that one
okay so not four not one
not four and not one
not five
no not that one either not that one
not that one
oh okay
thank you Nico yeah everybody's gonna be
asking wait where is this all right I
need you guys to help help me choose
here
so for me for me for me
I've got it narrowed down to it's either
going to be this one right here no oh
wait not that one not that one
okay yeah yeah all right so forget the
numbers I was just throwing out
this is number one right here this is
number one
so get a good look at that one that's
number one
that's number two
and that's number three
[Music]
Noob with five more gifted Subs
thank you so much Noob or gifted
memberships I'm sorry
[Music]
Haiku Warrior says three Draven also
says three so we're trying to decide
between this one right here
this one and this one
yeah that one like feels like a little
how are you welcome this may have been
me what uh before I lost some weight
after covet
I've always been on the smaller side
and then in covet I got to be the
heaviest I'd ever been
and then lost like I don't know 15
almost 20 pounds
after it so this may have been me during
like the covet time so this one looks
yeah okay so two or three looks like
most everybody's saying three
oh sorry uh cats had won a couple more
twos chin is smaller than the top of
your head
ah I feel like three is like that too
though
do another pull
just to decide my facial structure on
this random uh
L one's like two
don't trust the chat it's two
hold on hold on what if we do like give
you guys like a little side I'll see the
beard like with the beard you can't all
right hold on this could be this could
be the deciding factor though
let's go back now and add the beard to
those two faces
okay so there's that one and we really
don't have a shorter one
oh no definitely not that okay that
one's too long yeah so this is the
closest beard
all right so we were trying to decide
between this one oh it's basically no
difference
basically no difference with the beard
there is a little something more with
the the cheekbone right there
on two but not a lot I think it just
kind of shifts the perspective
Ellen wait add the beard I didn't see
that before I did it
oh
yep the beer definitely changed dirt
back face what's up welcome
fandom draws I didn't even realize you
were here Phantom draws but thank you
for hanging out have a good one
Alicia picked two or else okay so this
is the one I said is number two
ah I mean I feel like this one is just
like a little bit smaller
overall they're they're very close
though they're very close
uh Jake go to wizardingworld.com it's a
new thing they've added
wizardingworld.com and you can create
your own ultimate Wizarding World Avatar
Tom what's up Tom
Phantom got roasted wait what happened
to Phantom
yeah
oh Phantom no no I wasn't roasting
fandom I just feel bad like if I've if
I've missed people
if I miss people chatting I want them to
know my apologies not not calling them
out come on now
come on
I will Alicia yeah I like that take a
look at everybody's in the chat or in
the uh in the Discord had a nightmare
the Hogwarts Legacy got an MMO expensive
had nfts on character creation and
customization oh my gosh
whoo boy
well uh I think that would that would
change things a bit
all right so I think I'm good with
everything else the eyes
I was trying to decide between yeah I
think those eyes are good I'm not gonna
go with glasses even though I do wear
glasses occasionally
[Music]
oh that one is
no
yeah I think we're good I like the mouth
I don't think I want to be wearing a hat
either
we're gonna go with my younger self I'm
gonna give myself a little more hair
come on I mean I don't want to go with
like the full that doesn't look bad
though
but man when you put those that one pair
of eyes and you went with the bald and
then the red oh that was Voldemort
all right I think I think I want to wear
the tie
but I do kind of like just the hoodie as
well
definitely that one right there
oh we can go with a scarf too okay wait
spew spew
prefect ooh do I want to be a prefect a
head boy
or just the sky I don't really like how
the scarf looks Mark of the Deathly
Hallows is kind of cool
very close to number two uh Danny said
all right we went with two we went with
two
foreign
[Music]
I'm sure yeah
and when I every now and then I'll shave
and my wife says I look
too young I'm like don't I want to look
younger now honey the age we're getting
don't I want to look younger
wife likes the beard so the beard stays
but I do look anytime I've ever shaved
people tell me I look so much younger
without it so I'm kind of like
don't I want to look younger but hey the
wife likes it so the beard stays around
hey good night Danny thanks for hanging
out
do it during school while you're bored
nice
Mr member chat wait what did you chat
feathers
like when you rejoined
[Music]
or uh re-upped your membership
oh my gosh the ghost
I'm caught up I'm caught up I'll try to
uh
[Music]
oh my gosh if these Avatar portraits
transferred over
Dirtbag I do or did stream on Twitch
and I may again in the future some but
it would be a different type of stream
it would just be I think solely gameplay
here is definitely my home for these
types of just hangout streams
[Music]
but yeah I do have a twitch if you want
to follow it it's just the same name
[Music]
retro reckon tour
I'm waiting feathers I'm waiting if I
see it again
Noob agrees with the wife all right all
right
this is my chat before okay nice
remember that third person Sebastian
trailer that Chandler referenced on
Twitter that's a Malfoy
the one from the uh
the dark arts trailer
interesting
it very well could be
he was kind of playing it up
he was kind of playing it up
I remember that now
yep there you go there's the twitch
thank you Nico
happy spouse happy house I saw Elwyn
said happy wife
right I mean
[Music]
she's your outfit first then except yeah
I think I'm good with this I think this
is the outfit I want I think I want this
one
and I think I want the wand and I did I
already picked the owl too
I didn't look at any of the other stuff
though nah definitely not that
not the snitch I want the banners
oh I didn't even know about this one
Jake what are you kidding me dude
Jake with a 1999 Super Chat favorite
YouTube streamer and of course expecto
go showing support again yes I meant to
do the 20. Jake my man dude thank you so
much
very much appreciated and I know James
always appreciates the love and support
as well
but seriously you guys are you guys are
too much dude too much
oh you could do a blue background
I mean Blue's my favorite color but it
kind of takes away from the Gryffindor
vibes
all right I know I'm jumping out of
order I want to stick with the owl
though too I did already decide on the
owl so really the only thing I'm trying
to figure out is the all right let's
just go with a basic background for now
just in Gray
and then we're going to figure out
this one right here
head boy girl school positions house
spaces just two students out of the
whole school
wait wait you're making me second guess
now
oh Malfoy or Ravenclaw that would
yeah popcorn Wizarding World if you just
go Wizarding world.com it's like one of
their top stories right now
because of Jake I agree with him
blue is the best color Jenny says yeah I
like the blue a lot it's just I feel
like it kind of clashes with my
let me know what you find on the
research Felicia
because out
prefix are obviously for every house
but then I feel like head boy and head
girl
[Music]
the pan above that has 10 minutes on it
you mean the nine and three quarters
this one right here
so we got Weasley as our King
we've got spew Society for the promotion
of elfish where
welfare
platform nine and three quarters D.A
for Dumbledore's Army Mark of the
Deathly Hallows
Potter stinks
Curran re-upping the membership as well
current yo thank you so much continuing
to show support here tonight
by becoming a channel member once again
that's the two months from current
and then you got prefect
head girl head boy
the scarves I'm not I don't like the
scarves so at least with what I'm
wearing
now if I went with like
no
it looks better with that I feel like
with this one I don't feel like the
scarf works as well
I'm kind of leaning toward
oh
Weasley is our King
that one is funny
all right I'm leaning toward
none of the first three none of the
scarves not Potter stinks
so like why would you go I'm like why
would you go with prefect and not just
go with head boy or head girl
what I mean if you're gonna go you might
as well go go all the way right overhead
girl
dig the book references yeah I like the
D.A and I like the Deathly Hallows
the 10 minute pin thing above group chat
I'm not sure what you're talking about
Jake the 10 minute pin
where do you see 10 minutes
I don't see any I can't see anything
with with 10 minutes
wait what did Elwyn say
true that era Alicia said true D.A Ryan
went with D.A pick prefect feels
personal Deathly Hallows for DJing
Deathly Hallows for high IQ Jenny also
Deathly Hallows
a lot of Deathly Hallows choices
if you're creating this for you when
you're 15 uh okay gotcha
or yeah like you could you could go with
just the tie you don't need anything
else
oh thank you Nico and retro guy yeah
yeah yeah thank you
all right I haven't seen a lot of
Dumbledore's Army
which would be kind of weird for
if we put it in Hogwarts Legacy time I
don't really like the looks of that one
as much
oh the head boy one has like a special
little
headset that maybe someone chose prefet
because they didn't want all the uh yeah
that's true
could be yeah I feel like there's just
one head boy and one head girl for the
whole school
but maybe it's per house
all right I'm gonna go with my gut my
first instinct even though all of you
said it too my first instinct was
Deathly Hallows so I'm gonna go Deathly
Hallows
but I like the wand although I do love I
feel like this looks like uh this looks
like our Field Guide
right here
wretch overhead girl no not happening
Noob not happening
thank you for the Super Chat
but not happening
man I cannot get my throat clear
well you said in chat earlier two
seventh year students for the whole
school gotcha thank you Alicia that's
what I was leaning toward but yeah I do
like that one I do like the the staff as
well dude you're like the witch doctor
or something right here the uh
plague doctor
but I'm just gonna go with the wand
then I went with the owl and I chose the
oh I wait I didn't see the bow truckle
oh
oh my goodness
he's almost he looks a little too big I
should just look at all these though
he got the niffler
okay you guys know you guys already know
I can't have the cat that close
no no on the toad definite no on the rat
yeah I gotta go with the owl the snowy
owl
Dumbledore doesn't say head boys and
head girls that's true
good point Mary
[Music]
too big but still cute yeah he is
all right and then
yeah we already decided on that one okay
this one
definite no on the yellow
the blue looks good but I I don't I'm
either gonna go with the red
because it matches
or I'm gonna go with the gray
foreign
right there
retro rat
that thing was hard for me to choose one
would have them all but the toad and the
Rat
yeah the red does kind of really blend
in with the robes too
proud of my comment talking about
sneaking in other common rooms with
Paula juice doesn't that take a month to
brew I think it takes
yeah I think a month a month does sound
right
hold on I'm gonna mute the
my son my youngest son's bedroom is like
right above where I stream
and if he gets up I can usually hear him
so I thought I heard something but
just making sure
okay I think I think we're good
might have been the music the bass and
the music
foreign
fertilizers speed it up hey we got the
ancient magic though so
like that's gonna be their cop out for
everything in this game that like they
want to break the lore they could just
be like
ancient Magic
boosts it
was contrasting
all right I kind of I actually kind of
think this one works even though
foreign
I definitely like this one I don't think
it looks as good with the gray
I'm gonna go with that
and then the outside I think I'm gonna
stick with the black one that's what I
first switched it to although I like
that one too
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna go that one
all right I don't know what okay save
wait where did it save
complete portrait save and exit
oh my gosh here we go
oh there I am
okay now now does that appear somewhere
oh it does
let's go
[Music]
right above your Patronus and your house
and your wand
and your uh yeah Patronus
tortoiseshell cat
come on now
come on now
you missed the frame
like you didn't set your frame you
forgot to do that Mary
get into Hogwarts and start yelling
I won't be able to stop you hey you're
calling upon some very ancient magic
there with that one
Dragon breaks from Elder Scrolls right
want to pass the owls ancient Magic
rats as pets make no sense they allow
cats
I never really understood the rats or
the Toads to be honest
like why wouldn't it wouldn't everybody
want an owl I mean that has the most
practical use
I feel like I should have went with a
brown now the brown goes better with the
red but it's all good looks like you can
edit it later anyway
this was cool thanks elwin for letting
everybody know about this
Ryan uh back regarding headwind head
girl yeah somebody figured it out it's
um it's just one for the whole school
[Music]
oh wait wait Ryan's got more details
here okay okay Headmaster of Hogwarts
the pair of students were instructed to
do duties to assist the school LED both
the prefix and in many cases the entire
student body there you go yeah so they
were kind of over so you got prefix one
from each house
[Music]
and then you've got head boy and head
girl who are over
all of them
that comes out of the Discord Elwyn
spotted this and shared it there for all
of us
and I had started it before the stream I
meant to start the stream off with this
and I totally forgot about I had the tab
open I don't know if you guys saw I
switched over to the tab there
[Music]
uh-oh Nico out here deducting points now
Kratos Raptor 85 hoping you can pick our
owl in the game
I hope so too I feel like we'll be able
to at first I thought no we're not gonna
be able to do pets and all that
and then after they showed the
that trailer
wait what is this
oh that's from Jake showing the uh
I just saw your message in the Discord
Jake yeah they were they were right the
10 minute thing so that's whenever you
do a super chat your message will like
stay up there for a little bit longer so
that's all you were seeing with that 10
minutes is just a timer
all right how should we wrap up I just
saw this about Albus Dumbledore quote
quiz
I'm afraid to do this live
we doubt there's a Harry Potter
character more quotable than Albus
Dumbledore can you finish these
Dumbledore lines from the books okay
wait how do I do it where why is it not
refresh
what is it broken
come on now
I never use Microsoft Edge but uh let's
try it do not update
oh wow it actually is working on
Microsoft Edge all right then
all right
hopefully I don't embarrass myself you
guys Albus Dumbledore quote quiz now
here's the question is it books or
movies okay from the books all right
can you finish these Dumbledore lines
from the book's 15 questions
all right I'll give you guys a minute if
you all want to follow along with me and
do this
no cheating now no cheating everybody
got to be honest we gotta see who uh
let's see who gets the most on this
Nico's power hungry discriminating
against slogans and now Alicia
zodiac what's up and they're right
useful you talk about the owls right
they're very useful
all right all right here we go here we
go
nitwit oh okay yep I know this one knit
with blubber odd mint
if you guys are following along I gotta
be careful I don't want to give you the
answer before you have a chance so you
all feel free go on and get ahead of me
if you're starting it go and get ahead
of me
I don't want to give away the answer to
you if I know it too quickly
no you guys aren't supposed to help me I
know this one I know this one is tweak
oh and you get okay so once you click
that's good to know it immediately
inputs it so I don't have time to change
it all right
uh yes another another very popular one
it does not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live remember that now I
am second guessing this one a bit
because
this might be a movie one I'm not
looking at chat
I'm not looking at chat this might be
when they change for the movie
the movie is 100 it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget to live remember
that but this one said the book
spend your life in your head it's
definitely not that give up on living
room I don't think it's that forget the
reals I think it's this one
okay
see that's where they're throwing me off
I'm like overthinking it when I'm like
did the movies change it
okay the truth Dumbledore's side it is a
beautiful and terrible thing and should
therefore be treated with
I think it's great caution
it is a beautiful and terrible thing and
should therefore be treated with great
caution
boom all right three for three three for
three
feathers I'm an overthinker
I feel like they're gonna get
progressively harder there are all kinds
of Courage said Dumbledore smiling it
takes a great deal of Bravery to stand
up to our enemies but just as much
to stand up to our friends that now that
one they did change for the movie but
they changed this part of it I think in
the movie it's um
it takes a great deal of Bravery to
stand up to our enemies but even more to
stand up to our friends
okay hold on though now this is tricky
I'm pretty sure it's stand up but it
could also be speak up
yes all right four for four
question
oh yeah this is a very common one it is
our choices Harry
far more than our abilities that show
what we truly are
wait that is I'm remembering that one a
little different
all right hold on the music's too loud
actually I'm gonna skip ahead a little
bit just get to a slightly different
it is our choices Harry that show what
we truly are far more than our abilities
yes five for five
all right next question
you think the dead we have wait you
think the dead we have loved
oh come on ever truly leave us ever
really leave us
it's not ever stop loving us it's not
ever really depart our hearts
oh the ones we love never truly leave us
I think that's a serious quote in the
movies
you think the dead we have loved ever
truly
leave us
I'm gonna say truly
yes oh
I was afraid I missed that one
I feel like Chad's doing pretty well so
far too I feel like you guys are doing
pretty well
all right we're six for six next
question
so you did see your father last night
Harry
you found him inside yourself
his love for you summoned prongs
his love helped you cast that Patronus
you summoned his memory in a time oh
dude okay this one gut reaction it's not
ringing a bell at all obviously this is
Prisoner mask man
um so he's already cast the Patronus
this is at the end of the book they've
already went back in time
so Dumbledore is explaining to him so
you did see your father last night Harry
found him inside yourself no
his love for you summoned prongs no I
don't think so
I think it's this one his love helped
you cast that Patronus
no
I did not you found him inside yourself
[Music]
that did not
that did not seem right to me
[Music]
didn't get that yeah it's awesome
oh you're talking about uh that doesn't
sound right
his love helped you cast or no you found
him inside yourself
yeah I remember that one all right well
you had to miss one at some point right
we're six of seven now
oh I remember this one I used to have
this on my uh when it was a thing to
like put quotes on your Facebook I had
this on my Facebook page for a while
back in college differences of habit and
language are nothing at all if our aims
are identical I'm not even gonna look
it's and our hearts open
boom
there we go all right back on track back
on track
all right here we go indeed your failure
to understand that there are things much
worse than death has always been
I think he's talking to Tom here
[Music]
well I don't know this one
all of them could obviously work for
what he's explaining to Voldemort I feel
like greatest weakness was my gut
your failure to understand that there
are things much worse than death has
always been
I'm gonna go greatest weakness
no
let's go
oh yeah they need the earwax on here
so yeah eight fall ASMR could really be
any day at this point could really be
any day but who knows we may get more
stuff the rest of this week I have no
idea
no idea but yeah I hope to be over uh
pop in at least for a little while and
expect to go stream as well
Noob oh my gosh Noob dude
another Super Chat from noob
thank you uh retro you're awesome dude
you never failed to brighten my day glad
I can support you as much as I can still
waiting on that niffler holding the coin
uh Noob we will get the niffler
we will get the niffler
for you I will get the niffler dude
thank you so much man all the crazy
amount of super chats tonight new very
much appreciated all the gifteds Alicia
got an interview yo good luck Alicia
good luck
that's another thing high IQ Warrior I
almost feel like Halloween
maybe they do something a little bit
more than just the ASMR
you guys I'm not even kidding right now
I just realized who was it um
somebody said something about the a Gabe
thanks for the awesome community
I'm just scrolling back through here in
my chat
[Music]
almost every name is green
being a member how is Mary is always
here how has Mary not got one of the
gifteds that's
J Rossi I haven't seen Jay Rossi tonight
J Rossi Got A Gifted last time and J
Ross is usually always here
maybe next time Mary maybe next time but
guys thank you for the crazy amount of
support tonight it really has been
awesome even on kind of a slow news day
like this see the love and support from
the stream uh the Discord is hopping man
Discord is uh amazing oh wait that's
right Mary she cannot elwin that
explains it she cannot her type of
YouTube account will not allow her to um
I think I'm remembering the right person
I think it will not let
Mary get I think she has like a business
account or something
yeah if you guys aren't in the Discord
I'm not gonna hit exclamation point
Discord again because it's I think it's
the wrong one but Nico right on cue
there Nico's got it that link should
work
all sorts of fun happening there in the
Discord it's a good way to keep up with
people from that you may meet in the
Stream
that especially since we only stream
once a week right now
right now right now one day one day you
guys will be able to stream stream more
Nico got it covered
yes he does
all right man I think that's it guys I
think that's it thank you all so much
for the support So if you're new here
you'll you might see an ad on the way
out
if you want to go ahead and click away
it's all good I just hit it at the end
of the stream once I'm already logged
off it's just an easy way to support if
you're here and you want to hang around
and watch a quick ad it supports the
stream or go and get a drink come back
or whatever then click out it's just an
easy way to support the Stream So
sometimes people freak out they're like
why am I seeing an ad don't worry you
didn't miss anything I stopped talking
before I hit that button
um but yeah man it's been crazy thank
you all so much I hope everybody has a
fantastic rest of your week and we'll
see what else we get with Hogwarts
Legacy later this week so thank you all
so much I will talk to you again soon
feathers on premium I don't think you'll
have to watch it but I think I I get I
like still get credit for it so it's
kind of nice
all right guys have a good one